what is your ideal body type i would say
someone who's like fit someone who could
definitely just like throw me around
noted
[Music]
my name is makai i'm 23 years old i'm
from los angeles california and i do
social media marketing i would say my
body type is someone that's very slim
um
someone that keeps up with themselves i
i wouldn't say tall but just someone
around my around my height as long as
she's not like three or four feet taller
than me okay
oh
i'm not the the biggest or the
strongest but i know that i have
some great qualities so i like my body
i'm always going to be confident about
myself
[Music]
interesting
very interesting toes i'm going to say
there are some people that do keep up
with their toes
there's also
some women who i feel like my toes look
a little bit better than oh
what is your ideal body type so someone
that's fit not really that they have to
be like really strong and very like i
guess muscular but more that they like
have a confidence about themselves
really the personality like really makes
or breaks if i like them or not and that
they like the outdoors and being active
because if they can't do active stuff
with me it's really hard for me to want
to like connect with them okay tall
fit
but not too big because i'm i'm kind of
a small person so
not like you can kill me
like they're kidnapping you yeah
you don't need to be a gym rat or look
like chris evans although he's pretty
fine and captain america's ass could
like you know be down with it but you
don't need to look like that for me to
be like into you i do prefer somebody
who's taller than me the the most i'll
go shorter than me is like two inches um
i'm sorry babe not two feet but two
inches
i would say someone who's like fit and
like takes care of themselves someone
who could definitely just like throw me
around yeah
noted i have dated people of like all
different heights and body types so i
don't discriminate over here baby i mean
i noticed the tattoo bitter sweet and i
gotta say i really dig that thank you
now are you lovely ladies into tattoos
at all
okay music to my ears i have
three okay okay
you gotta catch up baby i got like eight
yeah oh [ __ ] i got six quite a few of us
back we have tattoos we only have two i
feel like
on our next date we could uh go to a
tattoo shop
[Music]
i'm probably
going to have to go based on the feet
i love the answers from this one but i'm
going to have to eliminate number one
[Music]
oh hi hey nice to meet you hey you got a
tattoo
nice to meet you too
i don't know they just they're the only
ones not really done yeah
i hike and like
lift so nail polish just gets rubbed off
yeah i like going hiking too yeah i
messed up
[Music]
okay
so some are a little bit revealing and
others
i see shorts yeah okay what's up with
the shorts um my parents are going to
watch this and
my parents yeah this is like
conservative i think for me whoa
conservative okay okay nice and then
number five although there's a lot of
tattoos over there i like that
tattoo yeah i have like little kind of
random bangers all over like little
stick and poke style ones i'm a stripper
so i'm like in my underwear for a living
so this is also very conservative for me
okay yeah a stripper what's what's your
um favorite thing about stripping
the money um
i went a little bit more conservative
this is not the norm i i just you know i
think there's something to leaving a
little
something to the imagination right right
now there was someone earlier who
mentioned uh being thrown around
um hi
now
i have a personalized question for you
oh no what's your biggest turn on um
probably oh no i can't say that
i would just say like someone who cares
about pleasing the other person more
than themselves
okay how comfortable are you in your own
body um i think when i was growing up i
wasn't um but then as i got older
honestly i think that i kind of had a
glow up but yeah i'm pretty confident as
you can kind of tell shout out to that
yeah i'm pretty confident and
comfortable in my body but it was a
process like i don't think it naturally
came to me i've always kind of been like
the bigger taller girl and also being
like biracial and and growing up with
like a white mom it took me a lot of
time to kind of be comfortable in my
skin back in school i used it to be made
fun of for being like real skinny i'm
trying to learn how to love my body
throughout all stages and be comfortable
in it no matter what it looks like i'm
like cute all the time so yeah
nice we all have our insecurities and i
definitely have some but i go to the gym
a couple times a week and i've been
weight training for almost like the past
year and i feel like that's helped with
my confidence and feeling comfortable
with my body a lot there's a lot of
pressure in the industry to get plastic
surgery and stuff like that and i'm very
pro plastic surgery but it is something
that you know just being around a lot of
people who have it you think like maybe
should do i need it should i get it but
i'd say for the most part i am pretty
confident in my body yeah
i like that we love a confident queen
right
um how confident are you in your body
yeah i'm definitely confident in my body
oh yeah all right yeah i found it yeah
yeah
how many am i eliminating this right now
oh my god
okay
oh my gosh
i'm going to eliminate number
three
okay
hi babes
funny hey to meet you nice to meet you
too i like your tattoos thank you
we'll link up it's cool see ya
damn this is hard as hell like i don't
want to eliminate anybody
number two
hi
i'm angelica
nice to meet you nice to meet you as
well i i thought you were going to be
taller than me so i was like yeah like
i'm tall
it'd be like that it's okay no harm no
foul it's okay
[Music]
okay
so let's see what's your least favorite
thing on your body either my boobs or my
nose
i don't think i'd ever get a boob job
though even though like i'm kind of
insecure about my boobs i don't want to
be like yeah
i'm gonna do what you want me to do so
i'm gonna do the opposite instead what
does that key mean
it's the key to my heart
i like that you want it i might have to
take that right now i'm confident and
i'm happy with the body type i have but
at the same time if i'm feeling insecure
or if i'm experiencing like body
dysmorphia or anything like that it's
almost a situation where it's not
accepted for me to have those
insecurities or voice them because
somebody might be a different type of
body type that's more targeted in a bad
way with society so i will say like
being a curvier girl i do have like
obviously like more belly and more leg
than
a lot of like instagram models and stuff
do obviously like everyone has their
angles and stuff that you could like
kind of
hide that a little bit why are you
single and what do you look for in a
partner i'm single because probably
because of my bad taste in guys i've
only been in one relationship
technically and we never even labelled
it because it was just so toxic and
honestly like emotionally abusive i
would say i'm single right now just
because i'm a very picky person i'm open
to going out and casually dating and
just having fun i'm not necessarily like
looking for the one or like anything i
actually moved out here from the east
coast with my ex at the time so put on
my best clown makeup and came out here
and it didn't
work out it did not work out i'm looking
for someone that's wholesome
[Music]
okay
so the person i'm going to have to
eliminate unfortunately is number
three
[Music]
hot hi
damn i love your hair thank you
hi hi emily i'm a kind nice to meet you
thank you i like your tattoos you have a
nice nice story
you do have nice he has really has nice
eyes by the way he really thank you i
appreciate that
i like the hearts thank you
i'm going to have to eliminate number
two
i don't know like you just seemed very
very shy i liked your answers yeah i got
like the same glasses as you do what's
your vision are you uh you're far sided
i am
near side where you can see right right
yeah can you give me again you want to
take my glasses off yeah can i see you
oh you're just i don't know
i got [ __ ] up
like 3d huh it's like a little stronger
than mine so yeah yeah oh i know i'm
sorry don't be sorry you're good it was
nice meeting you thank you
[Music]
hi hi hello i'm makai can i help you
yeah of course i've been liking everyone
hello hi maddie um you have nice tattoos
and i like your answers as well
especially with the key to the heart
thing that one no i'm definitely excited
to see like what happened such awkward
eye contact right now
can i have your number instagram
y'all actually do make like a really
cute hubble so like um